das vor ort heute gibt's ein kleines
mädchen mit früchten das ist ein schoko
teig das ist ein ganz normaler bis
mittag mit diesem öl und wasser damit
etwas feuchter wird es wahrscheinlich
jeder kennt kocht man daheim mit der
mama und backt mit der mama und soweit
auch immer ganz früh in der küche und
habe schon viel gekocht und gebacken und
irgendwann bin ich durch zufall auf ein
amerikanisches koch video gestoßen und
habe das eben bei youtube gesehen vorher
war das noch nie so aktuell bei mir und
dann habe ich irgendwie gedacht okay das
gibt es im deutschsprachigen noch gar
nicht und ich probier's jetzt einfach
mal
ich schaue natürlich immer ganz viel in
koch- und backbücher im internet gehe
ich natürlich auch ein bisschen
spazieren und sowohl mit der
inspirationen aber im endeffekt stelle
ich ihnen mein rezept selber zusammen
mir ist nämlich früher ganz oft schon
passiert dass ein rezept eins zu eins
nach gemacht habe und nicht meinem
instinkt gefolgt bin und dann ging das
rezept schien die creme besteht aus wald
wären also ganz bunt gemischt
heidelbeeren und himbeeren brombeeren
und natürlich auch johannes bergmann ist
sauer sind von youtube kann man wirklich
schon leben jetzt auch für ein jahr oder
zwei jahre meine lehrtätigkeit leider in
den pausen finden pausieren lassen weil
wir einfach den fokus darauf legen
möchten und ich natürlich auch die bug-
und kopf kochkurse geben möchte und ja
man kann wirklich davon leben will muss
alles richtig macht und man muss sich
aber immer selber treu bleiben getoppt
wird das ganze mit namens schoko sahne
und die wir da mit dem spritzbeutel
aufgespritzt und mit einem frucht
spiegel nährt zu tun spielt so aussehen
dass ich auch den laden hier in basel
haben werde als in den eigenen shops
peter buck und kochkurse geben es wird
eine eigene fernsehsendung geben
ich werde ein backbuch schreiben und ja
das sind so meine ziele und natürlich
noch größer werden